nobody knows what the 49ers are going to
do
some believe they could change their
minds multiple times between now and
thursday some believe they have changed
their minds
and some believe they are relishing in
this mystery that has been concocted
in the weeks since they moved up to
number three when we all thought
they had one guy one guy and now
i don't know how many guys five guys
yeah that's what maybe
more i don't know i doubt it's more than
five but it's amazing to me
it is amazing i mean you know first i
think he gave us some context clues
during the press conference yesterday
that tell you you know at least where
his brain was at
or thoughts or anything like that i mean
listen he gave us some honest answers
but i think there's some other things
you could read into too
you know i i do think there was the
point a little bit where
to your point mike about talking about
the one guy he makes a
a pretty broad statement you know hey we
were sitting that there at 12 we weren't
sure if the guy we
wanted was going to be there so that was
a little like
okay my my antennas went up when i heard
that oh okay yep there was one guy
okay and then i think he's pretty honest
after that they got to his spot
they did like all the quarterbacks and
they dug in a little bit more to do a
little bit more homework on all of them
he definitely was honest when he said we
all could be dead by sunday because
technically he
is right for more of what was said
yesterday both by kyle shanahan and by
49ers gm
john lynch let's have a listen everyone
has you know in your contract you do
this the draft is is mine but i told
kyle from
the beginning that this is he and i are
doing this together and when it comes to
quarterbacks
i'd be foolish i believe we have a head
coach who's also our offensive play
caller i will always defer to him
and you know what's cool about that is
that kyle i think respects my opinion
enough
he always wants it and ultimately we
arrive at decisions
we will and come thursday we'll have a
pick that hopefully makes everyone proud
but that will be judged in years to come
you know we knew that there was three at
the time exactly that's why we thought
three was
a good spot to go to after going through
this whole process
i feel good about five guys at three um
yeah we had
a guy probably at first back then but we
knew that wasn't set in stone yeah we
probably started with one in mind but
that one's gotten better since and so of
all the other candidates
um so do we know exactly who we want
maybe
probably but maybe not i i don't feel
like
i don't feel like we need to say that
and that's not just for
our case but like you know lots of stuff
happens between now and the draft and i
don't
you don't want the whole league knowing
exactly what you're set on four days
before the draft
yeah i mean one or more of the
candidates at number three could be dead
by the draft taking his answer from
earlier to its logical conclusion there
was a lot there though
and one comment that really stood out to
me
john lynch is when he said this will be
judged in the years to come
because to the extent that there is
a difference of opinion between plug and
play mac jones who may have a ceiling
that isn't as high as a trailer
develop and wait for trey lance maybe
even adjusting fields hey
i got a former gm insisting that it's
fields
insisting that it's fields which is
stunning to me well is this the same gm
that was telling you
uh you had another you know what was
your other one
what they told me you were a good
quarterback yeah it's the same one okay
same one
wasn't there a crazy one you brought up
on the show last week that it was
insisting something and we kind of got
on them but either way okay
all right so they have this it's justin
fields i'll tell you during the break
yes who this former gm is okay but uh
right but but
but look it could be when they say five
guys
who are the five the top five
quarterbacks that
it's trevor lawrence zach wilson mack
jones justin fields trey lance and we
know it's lawrence and wilson
off the board see when they made the
move
the obvious reaction just like when the
jets made the move to three
six weeks before the draft in 2018. hey
they're comfortable being third in line
right assuming it's quarterback
quarterback and for the jets it was just
one quarterback and then a running back
so they got the second quarterback on
their board
so hey the 49ers get the third
quarterback on their board whoever it
may be
there's no unl i don't
i don't like creating the sense that
they have now turned it into a shell
game
for themselves as to who the guy is
going to be
you go from having conviction that it's
one to putting yourself in a spot where
you've taken a deep dive a close look
attended the pro day workouts of
three and because at some point you got
to pick one yeah and more importantly
more importantly chris
when you pick one you got to watch what
the other two
do with other teams it's not like they
disappear
sure i was thinking this before the show
this is like
going into an expensive automobile
dealership with the idea
that you're buying the ferrari okay
going
i got the money i took out the huge loan
right mortgage of the future
i'm getting the ferrari you walk in
you got a ferrari you got a porsche you
got an aston martin in there
sure and all of a sudden you realize but
these drive good too
i kind of like these other two cars
here's the difference yeah whichever one
you take
your neighbors are gonna have the other
two yeah sure they're buying the other
two
you got to see the other two you got to
drive down the street
next to them in that other one that
other one may end up being held a lot
nicer than the one you bought
yeah listen i mean that that was a good
analogy
uh certainly and you're right you know i
think that's what he talked about like
you know what we saw early on with the
clip with the social media and am i
gonna let the pressure get to me and all
that type of stuff
you know yeah there's a lot of noise out
there and of course yeah shanahan's name
and
whatever quarterback he does draft
they're going to be tied to
you know fields or lance throughout
their careers they're going to
be compared constantly there's no doubt
about it especially as controversial as
this became
you know as far as you know oh you can't
take mac jones at three how could he be
better than
justin fields and man trey lance and all
the potential he has
but i still think like even to your
point mike like
i i i still think shanahan
went into it going i like ferrari and
got to the store and went i like ferrari
but oh this is a great porsche and aston
martin
let me let me take it out for a test
drive and see and
and just make sure because i'm spending
all this money to get the ferrari
anyways maybe i'll like these more
and then okay you take a test drive and
now you're back down to
okay this is the car i want i still
think
just by what we heard yesterday right
that
you know the original guy that was
traded up for
is still the guy at least that's what i
came away from that press conference
thinking
i really did you know even with a little
comment there at the end where he was
like um
he talks about what what exactly did he
say he just said
well even the guy we were originally on
he got better too
right so that that tell that gave me a
little context clue that like
okay that guy checked the boxes that
that's the guy going forward so we'll
see who it is
i mean again i think it is mac jones
there's no doubt i haven't waffled that
on
on like a bit but i understand the
intrigue
of the other guys and you know the more
you more you hear mike just like we've
heard here the last few days
you know i know they didn't make a
cancellation of any of them but man the
league
seems to think it's trey lance or mac
jones that has gotten out of that
building somehow
some way and i have a feeling it's come
down to
you know those two as well just by the
people you listen to in the media
let me give you a more appropriate
example than shopping for high-end cars
this would be
like washington 2012
making the big move up to number two
where they're getting andrew luck or rg3
and at the time
we assumed the colts were leaning hard
andrew luck but rg3 was in the
discussion i remember tony dungey saying
he'd take rg3 over andrew
former colts coach if you're the colts
you gotta at least listen rg3 declined a
private workout with the colts which
kind of slammed the door
on going to indianapolis but this would
be the equivalent of washington making
that big move when the shanahans were
there even though it may not have been
their decision
to make the big move and then when they
get there well
we like four guys and all of a sudden
it's rg3
or ryan tannehill or brandon whedon
all three of whom went the first 22
picks that year right
and and what look
it does create a lot more interest and
the 49ers have essentially hijacked the
draft because
we know what the jaguars are going to do
we know what the jets are going to do
but man you really are putting yourself
in a position
where this could blow up in your face
because history tells us
a certain percentage of these
quarterbacks taken in round one or along
with the other players sure going to
stink
what if they pick the one who ends up
stinking now kyle shanahan may have
something to do with whether or not he
stinks
but it just it this is a high wire act
that they have voluntarily engaged in
right and i'm not sure they really
thought through what the potential
ramifications are because the potential
ramifications are they buy the lemon
and the other two cars run great right
for 10 years
no i and that's that's the scary thing
you know and i think that's where
you know coaches get concerned about
now what you're talking about like the
public perception a little bit
and a little bit of just the the the
sound and everything around
all of that type of stuff because you
know too the where you
where what you're talking about of
course they're the coach the quarterback
they're going to pay attention to the
other two guys how their careers go
everything like that
the fans are going to be all over it and
whoever they draft
is going to be held to that standard
throughout their career
i mean it's almost you know it's almost
going to be a little bit of a no-win
situation
until whoever that quarterback is for
the 49ers just
you know smacks everybody besides the
face 30 times i was like look we're good
i'm good and there's nothing you could
do about it and finally you know shut up
everybody it's going to take like
probably some playoff appearances and
some
unbelievable statistics to go along with
it to silence the haters
on this conversation uh that yeah
there's going to be that part of it
but that really only comes down to like
the mac jones part of it that's the uh
that's the
side i find interesting because it
doesn't seem like people are
all up in arms or crazy if trey lance or
justin fields get drafted
it's only the mac jones thing and that's
where it's where they're leaning
it's where it's leaning and that's where
they see the microscope is and
everybody's on it even more so there is
this is a a career defining moment for
the the shanahan era with the 49ers i
don't think there's any doubt about that
this is a huge huge you know night we
got coming up for them here in a few
nights
they've made it even bigger by playing
this game
of which car will i buy yeah instead of
just making the move
not saying anything not not embracing
the mystery they've embraced it like i
was told last night they are relishing
this and that's fine
until you pull the pick once you pull
the pick you're going to say
maybe we maybe we should have been more
decisive maybe we should have been more
clear because by creating the appearance
of indecision
you're opening the door for the i told
you so doubters on the back
end you mentioned a couple of times what
shanahan had to say yesterday about
being influenced by social media and
obviously
he shouldn't be no one should be let's
hear from shanahan talking about
that specific angle i've seen the look
of
people's face when they do read social
media
i know how i've felt when i've done it
after a bad loss or something
or after a good win like whatever it is
is completely
inflated past reality and i hope that
any human nature if you get involved in
that i don't care who you are whether
you're a football coach a gm
a high school kid anybody if you get
involved in that it will affect
how you are how you think and what you
do and i hope
people and that will affect me if i got
really involved in that
but i can promise people that you have
two people who make sure we don't get
involved in that
because it is so irresponsible to let
something like that affect your decision
we do this for a living and
i think people should be proud of us
that we won't let that affect our
decision
um and then it's up to us to live with
the consequences
if i understand what he said let me boil
this down let me boil this down
when i look at social media it has an
impact on me but i'm not gonna let
social media have an impact on me even
though i look at social media and it has
an impact on me the dog is chasing his
tail in that response chris
well yeah i mean you know he's aware of
how the world works
he is but he is trying to block that
aspect out you know and you know i think
what he's trying to say there too or a
little bit to like what you said mike
you know
hey it does you know if you're if you're
be
if you're paying attention at a very
topical level it seems like there could
be
indecision you know but i think what
shanahan and lynch are trying to do
tell you yesterday a little bit it's not
indecision it's more due diligence
and trust us that we know what we're
doing and you know we're running an
organization and they've been running at
a pretty high level here the last few
years
i think that's what he's trying to say
more than anything so it's not in
decision it's just like
it'd be careless for me to go up to
number three
and then not really dig in to do the
homework on all these other guys
just to make sure because like you said
his life
his career going forward is going to be
compared to these other two quarterbacks
whoever would
which one he doesn't pick so he wants to
make sure he's
you know crossed every t
dotted every eye picked up every rock in
the world to make sure
that you know things are the way he
expected them to be
when he traded up to number three i
think that's what he's trying to say
so we'll see where it goes from here um
but i
i got the sense yesterday mike at least
that
you know again now it's not stone cold
but they know who they're picking i mean
i do think
that that's gone by they the the reports
we heard this weekend that the 49ers
have come
to you know a conclusion and know all
that i did get that sense yesterday at
least did didn't you
well i'd like to think they have a
decision made by now right i'd like to
think they had the decision made when
they made the pick see
chris here's here's the risk that kyle
shan is running and i'm on record
he's the the young version of bill
belichick potentially he could win a
bunch of super bowls potentially
he is putting a lot of eggs in this one
basket and there's a balance there that
you have to strike
between due diligence and
not being wishy-washy not creating the
impression that you could go through any
of three doors
because if the guy that you pick
does end up being the lemon among the
ferrari the porsche and the aston martin
if he ends up being the lemon it's so
much better if you can
sell oh it was never it was never an
issue
this was always my car i didn't i didn't
test drive the other two this was always
my car
this is why i got that loan this is why
i took a new 30-year
second mortgage on my house this is the
car i've always wanted
this is the car i thought was perfect
and you know what sometimes it doesn't
work out
when you allow yourself to flirt as
openly as they have with these other two
guys
and then embrace the mystery of what
you're going to do we don't need to let
anyone know what we're going to do well
it doesn't matter if they do
it's not like they're going to get
leapfrog for mac jones if they come out
right now and say it's mac jones it's
always been mac jones
they're not going to get leap frog for
mac jones no one's trading up with the
jets or the jaguars to get him
so maybe but is no but maybe he's no
strategic
well no what what if what if atlanta
really is hot on trey lance
what if they are hot on trey lance and
they really want them and now
atlanta's not sure so what if that
happens i mean we saw the 49ers
not long ago uh swip
switch a number two pick and become a
number three pick right
so i'm just throwing that out there
listen i did the same thing when
shanahan was like
i don't want the league to know i don't
want to tell anybody i kind of was like
why
i mean i was kind of thinking about that
but i i do think you have to hold out
hope for that type of possibility maybe
that maybe there is somebody really hot
on these guys and
okay maybe we drop down a spot or two
and still
know that i'm going to get the
quarterback i want to get i'm guessing
that's why they're keeping it secret
then why aren't the jets embracing the
possibility that mac jones could be
their guy to try to get the 49ers to
flip-flop or the jaguars
throwing out the idea that maybe zach
wilson's their guy to try to get the
jets to do a flip-flop why aren't the
other teams doing
well i i i think that you know one and
two
uh are everybody's one and two that
would be my
thought for the most part and then just
everybody thinks those two guys are
going there like
you know i i i haven't heard too many
people
venture off the wait trevor lawrence and
zach wilson
are one and two in this draft so that's
kind of just set in stone there i think
a little bit i guess it's a little
a little different of a conversation but
mike i don't know i'm not saying i know
i'm just
throwing it out there i i don't know who
took over the pr function there since
bob lang
left to go back to philadelphia but this
is going to be a pr
challenge because on the back end after
they make this pick they need to start
sending out the message this was always
the guy this was always the guy the rest
of it was strategic the rest of it was
window dressing and the balance on the
back end is going to be
not saying so much that you give a
career's worth of bulletin board
material to the guys you didn't pick
yeah you can't crap
on them right you can't say we didn't
really like tr trey lance and justin
fields we don't think they're going to
be good quarterbacks we understand
there's going to be
busts and we think they're more likely
to be the bus than our guy our guys but
you got it so there's they've just they
put themselves in a very difficult spot
before the draft and potentially after
the draft
because if they don't get the message
out to the faithful as they call them
that mac jones was always the guy and
maybe even if they do
they are stepping into this potential
problem where if jones doesn't work out
they're going to hear it from their fans
in their media for years to come
you should have taken lance you should
have taken fields and
and and i even though it's narrowed down
to lance
and jones if fields ends up being the
superstar of the bunch
they're going to hear you should have
taken fear no doubt they're definitely
going to get i told you so
you should have done this what were you
thinking all of those type of things
there's no doubt
the other thing too that i took away
though you know is just as far as i'm
looking for clues
there's a lot of like drew brees
references yesterday in that press
conference too towards the end which
again made me think like
it is a mac jones at quarterback but
we'll see
i mean you're right this is huge stuff
they have hijacked the draft all we've
talked about
is the 49ers ever since they made this
trade i mean
really have we ever talked less about
the number one and number two pick in
the draft ever i can't remember
it's a huge moment for their
organization i mean the pressure
the jimmy g situation 49 the shanahan's
name is going to be attached to this
forever
so uh yeah we'll see where this goes and
whoever they pick yeah they're going to
have to make sure they go all in to make
it work so so they don't get their butts
fired
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports